[Music]
all the things that I does memories they
never need the past more than memories
it's the devil you sold your soul to
[Music]
he's coming
he's coming to collect
[Applause]
[Music]
you
official Punisher trailer let's break
this down this is so great so everybody
was asking for that Comic Con footage
this is not what that is it's a little
bit different and it's coming in
November so I'll explain what's going on
with the release date because they're
doing something a little bit special
because if you could kind of tell from
the music from this in the footage
they're playing up the more military
aspect of the Punisher series the Comic
Con footage was actually playing up more
of the drug cartel side of things so
there's a couple different things going
on during the series but I am doing a
Netflix giveaway because defenders just
dropped and there's a bunch of defenders
dropping this weekend so all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video and of
course there's going to be all kinds of
punisher videos coming between now and
november - the weird thing about the
release date this is actually pretty
cool especially if you're a military
veteran because punisher is a military
veteran in the world of the TV show
that's Afghanistan and as that footage
implies you sort of flashback to some of
the terrible things that they did while
they were there in the comics it was
Vietnam but they found a way to work
that into daredevil season two when he
was talking to that guy I'll play that
clip in a second because it was actually
pretty cool like oh you were in the
military I was in the military - sure
not certain reading Division fighter
right you yeah yeah rack against no come
on
Thanks you were a jarhead I was a
jarhead too but there's a really
important day in November that has
nothing to do with Thanksgiving
typically that's when Netflix drop stuff
because people are on vacation so it's
like okay binge mode vacation but
because the military is so fundamental
to Punishers character Veterans Day is
on November 11th that's a Saturday but
you remember that Netflix always drop
stuff midnight on Thursday nights so
Friday the 10th is actually the birthday
of the Marine Corps so that is probably
when they're going to be dropping all
these episodes
there'll be 13 just like there are for
the other Netflix series so everybody's
complaining about how there's only eight
episodes of defenders well we're going
to get 13 episodes of Punisher kicking
freakin ass yes jigsaw is the main
villain of the series even though he
doesn't appear anywhere in this footage
that's more of the crime family mafia
aspect of the series so the Mafia is
like Marvel's version of the Mafia
jigsaw is hired by them to take down the
Punisher and that's how they start going
against each other like Mary Elizabeth
mastrantonio is one of the big
characters of the series she's going to
be playing Mary and James so I believe
that she's going to be a jeryn hogarth
type character like during Jessica Jones
series jeryn hogarth was a good
character who also did very terrible
things she actually wound up being kind
of an antagonist even though the purple
man was the main villain so I think
that's going to be her role in the
Punisher series in conjunction with
jigsaw jigsaw will sort of evolve into
with his crazy Punisher villain over the
course of season one you really see the
benefits of them slow baking a lot of
these characters the way they did with
the kingpin kingpin really big character
during daredevil season one and even
though he dealt with them he was much
more powerful in season two even though
he was still in prison the last time
that he ran into the Punisher they
didn't end things very well so he's kind
of on his [ __ ] list and in that Comic
Con clip that they showed off of
Punisher
he was dismantling a bunch of drug
organizations across a couple different
continents like during this promo you
see the gun [ __ ] you see him blow up a
couple big warehouses that's probably
from those aspects of this series but
you don't actually see any giant
warehouses of drugs or anything like
that you just hear that cool voice over
where he's
the devil you sold your soul to which I
liked the imagery there because of
daredevil the devil of Hell's Kitchen is
coming to collect so I think the idea is
is that in Afghanistan his Marine unit
did very terrible things turned him into
a devil like this killing machine then
they came back and obviously his
commander became one of the villains of
daredevil season 2 there was like sort
of a subplot for the Punisher he took
care of him so he grabs the micro DVD
that's micros a character from The
Punisher series if you seen spider-man
homecoming now the best way to describe
him is is the Punishers man in the chair
they show you that same unit killing his
family it actually looks like a much
more expanded version of what they were
doing during daredevil season 2 like you
learned a little bit about how his
family died in the park that day but
this actually seems a little bit
different so it seems like his old
Marine unit is trying to clean up the
pieces of the stuff that they've been
doing since Afghanistan and Punisher is
just going to go track them down but
also at the same time you have him
trying to dismantle the drug
organizations who his Marine unit might
be working with that might be the
connection because so far we haven't
seen that much of them aside from the
Irish that he dismantled during
daredevil season 2 that was one of the
first things that they did like they
opened the series with him gunning a
bunch of them down because they were in
the park that day that his family was
killed so he was really just going after
the people that he thought was
responsible for killing his family but
then it turned into this big
double-cross situation where all the
drug people were like we were
double-crossed two people wanted us in
that Park on that day so they could wipe
the board clean and it was his military
commander that had engineered this
situation where he was trying to get rid
of all this dirty laundry and shady
stuff that they had done so he's going
to kill all the people that were
involved with that but obviously
Punisher didn't die he worked his way up
the ladder so this was looks like a
continuation of that but you see him
hammering his symbol into the floor
they're like you get the idea that
somebody tried to bury the past like you
see them flashback to this scene here in
the basement it's kind of like John wick
like somebody tried to bury the past
pave over it and a Punisher is digging
it up like you thought that you could
bury the past no you can't bury all
these terrible things that you've done
the devil you sold your soul to is
coming to collect which is
cool because of the parody with
daredevil so no spoilers for defenders
but if you haven't yet be sure to start
watching defenders I'll start posting my
spoilery Easter egg videos tomorrow they
have changed a bunch of steps from the
comics about what's going on with the
characters so I'll try to explain that
when I post that first video but I've
already done a video for the Comic Con
footage that they showed off for
Punisher it's a lot different like I
said so I think it's in this video here
you can click here to find out about
that and you can click here for my
non-spoilery defenders review thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight